max friedman he's been on a roll
throwing the ball really well since he's
come off the il in his last eight starts
he's given up one run or less and six of
those and freed's first pitch of the
night is drilled in the air to deep left
field but back goes el monte it can't
make the catch on the warning track and
pillar will wind up at second base so
it's a lead off double for pilar here's
francisco lindor delivers and he went
around yes indeed lendore is down on
strikes freed comes back to get them at
shortstop one on one out and here's
conforto the next one on the way and he
came back from a 3-0 count to get
conforto so freed with a chance to get
through the inning after the lead-off
double and here's pete alonso pete hits
one of the air to deep left field forget
that that is way out of here alonso
cracks a two-run first inning home run
and the mets jump out to a two-nothing
lead he jumped all over that fast ball
from max freed and hit it almost halfway
up into those bleachers and left center
field the mets have been dominant this
year with their starting pitching and
david peterson lately has joined the
parade three straight solid starts for
the young left-hander and let's see if
ronald can get the night off to a good
start for the braves offense he's got a
three-game hitting streak
unloads
tape measure home run
oh there's one back fourth lead off home
run and that was a no doubter number 22
there are no sound effects added
to this
freddie single and a wild pitch here's
ozzy albee's and a line drive right
field base hit here comes freddie
goodford loads up
washes waving here comes the throw to
the plate
in time what a slide
50 rbis for albies who takes one the
other way and the braves have answered
the mets with two of their own so two
out nobody on now
swansea slashes one the other way
conforto diving to make the catch
second time on this road trip that
conforto has left his feet to make a
brilliant play devin pilar led off the
ball game with a double and eventually
scored and he strokes that one toward
right center field and cuny got a good
job did he hang on he
did what a catch two great plays by the
right fielders in the early innings
tonight two outs now he faces michael
conforto who's over one with a strikeout
and
strike three called conforto knew that
six punch outs for max free through
three innings he'll cool off one out
nobody on now ronald acuna jr will bat
strike three call nice pitch by peterson
to get acuna for the second out watch
the movement on this pitch starts right
at acuna and ends up tailing back over
freeman on the doorstep at third alby's
at second three balls two strikes on
austin reilly this will be the 10th
pitch of the battle swing in a line
drive left field base hit is going to
score two one in it bad for riley
atlanta takes the lead four to two
oh man was that ball scalded that one's
a fantastic at that you love seeing that
you love seeing guys battle and battle
and battle and get rewarded that was
freddie freeman's 900th run scored the
top of the fourth solanto draws a walk
and the mets have their first base
runner since james mccann walked
and freed takes care of mckinney
that's seven strikeouts from axe and
tour out into the bottom of the fourth
we go a runner third no one out a
one-one count on smith braves two for
three with runners in scoring position
in this ball game on the way ripped
through the left side and a base hit out
of kevin smith
five two braves is almonte scores and
the bottom of the order making some
noise here in the bottom of the fourth
inning
let's see now luis rojas is going out to
the mountain i think he's bringing some
company with him he's got jeremy hefner
and trainer brian chiclo i hope that's
not an oblique kind of thing maybe he's
got a little cramp and he's coming out
of this game might have been coming out
anyway because of performance but he's
coming out because of injury peterson
left the game with right side soreness
and sean reid foley who had gotten back
up in the bullpen is going to come on
free chose butt
butted hard back to the bow they're
screaming go two reed fully thrown away
now it's a race to the third base bag
look at freight advance he'll stand at
second that was the right play but reed
foley just pulled his throw to second
and the braves have him second and third
with nobody out now freddie freeman's
the batter
looped into left field that's down for a
hit that's going to score one
and max freed will stop at third base
two more hits for freddie freeman
tonight so aussie with a perfect knight
digs in he's two for two
and a looper into right field that's
gonna drop for a hit and score another
run
freeman will stop at second ozzie
albee's a perfect night he's three for
three with two rbis still just one out
here in the bottom of the fourth inning
two two
light drive right field one in it back
look at freddie streak around third
they're gonna wave him conforto's throw
is not cut off atlanta's got him first
and third again
oh man is this fun to watch
two hit night for riley three rbis for
him and swanson is on with a walk and
that'll load the bases so all nine will
come to the plate here in the bottom of
the fourth inning for the brave
line drive left center field that's
going to get down for a hit pilar chugs
over makes a play in left center two
runs score swanson at second horadia has
doubled home a pair
the braves are frolicking at home
tonight against the mets yeah another
hanging fastball
about the only saving grace in this is
that we're going to get to watch the
major league debut of thomas zupaki
one out
and the first one right back to the
mound and he's going to look the runner
to first throw two first missed the tag
and a run is going to score and they
didn't miss the tag on baker pardon they
got the out but it costs the pucky and
the mets a run now max freed will bat
for the second time in this inning
and that one gets away but it comes
right back to mccann again and this time
her radio made the break and he's in the
rundown
and zapucci gets the put out and that's
how his first big league inning ends
last of the fifth inning in atlanta the
braves 11 the mets ii and thomas
zuppucki will now start with a clean
slate and there's strike three called
and thomas zuppucki has his first big
league strikeout save that ball freddie
freeman has three hits tonight ozzie
albee's is three for three
swing and a drive ozzy on roads he's got
a fourth hit
off the facade of the second deck
bombs away in atlanta ga one at night
for the braves offense 13-2 jesse chavez
will take over for max free this is not
a surprising move with the huge atlanta
lead two out that'll bring up pete
alonso
alonzo was walking away he thought that
was strike three
and alan porter gives him a reprieve
well he had a right to think that was
strike three it was well i'll throw it
there again
there we go that takes care of a lot
zoning nods his head and said well you
should have called the other one but
all's good in atlanta freddie freeman
will be taken down and he'll give way to
eddie adrianza swinging a drive first
pitch adrianza look at that ball go
well no surprise there adrian's has been
really good off the bench this year they
will bring on albert almora jr this will
be his first big league pitching
appearance as the braves have the bases
loaded three balls in a strike even
jacob degrom is looking on as ender
takes ball four that'll bring home a run
so heredia scores a run there's the 1-1
pitch and he gets hit so painful rbi for
sandoval that is pablo's first rbi since
may the eighth one out here in the
inning and the braves now on top 17-2
ozzy unloads on the first pitch deep to
right that ball is gone he got his fifth
hit
and ozzy albee's has driven home seven
runs and the braves have scored 20. as
billy mckinney their final hope no balls
two strikes with two on the pitch
is a swing and a miss and that is your
ball game what a night for the braves
very simple to say this is an offense
that needed this this was a pitching
staff that needed this